for the break we had my exclusive
interview with the boss of Saudi funded
golf tour Greg Norman who described the
hypocrisy of his critics as Daphne well
joining me now is Jenny Clement again
I'm legendary boxing promoter Frank
Warren who's recently been in talks with
the Saudis to Stage potentially Tyson
Furies next fight well Frank great to
talk to you
um what is your view about all this
because the Saudis tentacles in sport go
a long way now whether it's football
clubs whether it's golf whether it's
boxing Formula One and the allegation
constantly put up there is that this is
morally wrong
and yet I see Sports doing business with
all sorts of dodgy regimes all the time
that aren't Saudi Arabia what do you
think
good evening peers uh what do I think
about it 24th of May this year the uh
the then prime minister Boris Johnson he
he hosted the aim the Emir of Qatar
sorry of Qatar and
they they invested 10 billion in this
country 10 billion and the Prime
Minister uh said it it uh showed a vote
of confidence in Britain the trade deal
energy deal and defense deal
Boris went to Saudi
um when the energy crisis started and
asked them to produce more oil he went
there on behalf of Britain so I the mess
the mixed messages going out I find
ridiculous you know it's okay for the
government to deal with them it's okay
for the government to sell arms to them
and yet we in sport shouldn't be doing
it so you know this where do we go this
our own government are doing and do you
think Frank do you think the when you
listen to Greg Norman there do you think
the the splitting golf really is about
money more than morality that the PGA
Tour the big tour don't want to lose
their best players to the very cash Rich
Live Tour and do you think inevitably
there'll be a deal and they'll have to
come together
uh that I don't know it is about money
you know I'll be very honest if you know
most Sportsmen not so much with golf but
most sports and certainly boxers have a
very short career so using Tyson
hypothetically if he was to be offered
to fight say 10 million in this country
and he was offered 30 to fight there
I mean who's to stop him doing that you
know they've hosted you've said they
hosted um those various events Formula
One Etc WWE WWE regularly run shows
there the Italian and Spanish super Cups
have been host staged there on a couple
of occasions and then I think about the
other Investments That Saudi have made
in other companies like EA
um Nintendo Walt Disney Uber and
Facebook yeah so I don't get any of this
I think
let me bring in Jenny I mean you're
shaking your head here I mean I I saw
this week a tweet from James cleverley
thanking uh Muhammad bin Salman the
Saudi Crown Prince of those helping
getting British hostages out of the
Russian hands in Ukraine
um how is it the weekend of the foreign
secretary thanking this guy if he's such
a pariah that we're not allowed to have
a golf tour sponsored by because we as a
country are unfortunately dependent on
on Saudi Arabia they buy our arms we
depend on them financially in a way that
I wish we didn't when it comes to sports
there is a choice we don't need this
investment from Saudi Arabia it's not
like Saudi Arabia desperately cares
about boxing or about golf what they
want is to co-op some of the good will
we feel about sport to make themselves
look better and if you look at for
example Russia over the past five ten
years the Sochi Winter Olympics Formula
One uh all sorts of of giant sporting
events that that took place there and we
turned the other way because at that
time with you know maybe Putin isn't it
it's your position that we should stop
having anything to do in a sporting
context with any country that has a bad
human rights record I think a country
because you do realize that if that's
your position that will pretty much wipe
out most major sports in the world from
continuing at the same commercial levels
I think that has to rise above it and it
shouldn't necessarily be about money
when you're talking about the most
important in Saudi no sport in China uh
yes no World Cup in Qatar yes I would
say that too nothing in Russia I mean
what you're doing you're very you're
basically saying right anywhere whose
regimes we don't approve of it's not no
no no which I would put this to you
after we illegally invaded Iraq in 2003
which should people have boycotted
British sport I'm not saying it's people
whose regimes countries the regimes we
don't agree with but you're saying
countries with an appalling human rights
record where people who oppose the
government aren't murdered where gay
people are murdered perhaps we should
say no we are not going to let you uh
burnish your image by uh by using even
if our governments continue to do
billions of pounds I think we should not
vote for governments that continue to do
billions of pounds I'd love to see the
labor party never do any business with
the Saudis particularly on oil let's go
back to Frank Frank I can't let you go
without asking Tyson Fury Anthony Joshua
there was a 5 PM deadline Tyson's gone
off on one basically saying that say
it's off I think there's still wriggle
room is there still wriggle room
or Tyson's adamant he gave the uh he
gave that deadline on Friday and again
repeats the next Saturday and I think
even yesterday and uh he's he said
enough is enough they've had to contract
for over 10 days we've had we've had
conversations today with the other side
but Tyson's had enough of it so
um you know that's it I mean he's the
guy he's the champion he's the guy that
matters
and he makes the decision and that's his
decision at the moment
do you think it's over
uh look um personally the only way it
could happen now if they sign the
contracts and and well they haven't even
sent back the contract with any
amendments on it so you know 10 days on
you thought we'd had something backed up
by now and there was positive talks
today but um it's just you know Tyson's
Tyson you know he feels he's giving well
a tremendous opportunity
losses my money paying 40 my bet is on
this fight happening and I've got
another bet if it does happen with Tyson
Fury which he made on this show live
which if he does get back in the ring I
get a million pounds off him so I have a
vested interest in this fight happening
well it's probably your fault it's your
fault it's not going on he can't afford
to
Frank brilliant to have you on the show
thank you very much mate much
appreciated Jenny great to see you thank
you very much indeed